You understand that your the idea that you went in there and
you just didn't want to prove anything really. That's kind of
absurd, right? >> So, I was insulted and I got angry. >> I
I said you were a bad friend. I didn't say you were a bad person.
That's synonymous in my mind. Like you know what >> Would it
make you a bad friend? Yes. Yes, because obviously if you're
going to discuss something that's being used to slander your
friend in public, you should apprise yourself of the
We watched the Pisco being on the panel with Taylor Lorenz and
Hutch. Pisco getting condescended to by Hutch repeatedly, right?
But just for the sake of, you know, refreshing your mind, when
Pisco would go to interrupt, this is the kind of thing he was
met with, right? >> But if you're going to take issue with
like random sort of characterizations and again I understand
>> it's random. I just think it was deliberate. I think
it was deliberate >> Okay, well I guess >> Why don't
you get to there? I mean like I mean why don't why don't you
go there and just ask Taylor?
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with her. I don't
know why you're jumping in >> Well, no no no because it's
kind >> So, Hutch, by the way, major gaslighting when he
goes to Pisco's stream and tries to tell Pisco, "Actually, what's
going on here is you were being really rude to me. You were actually
being a to me, Pisco."
So, this Usurp the Chef guy, who's like a big time Destiny cultist
guy, okay? This is the same guy who tried to get Pisco and Destiny
to talk before. Same guy, massive Destiny fan. He's the guy who
did this video. >> Hey son, how you doing? I'm happy I
was finally able to wake you out of your slump. Cuz for a while
>> The performative eating, the performative like, "Guys,
I'm making a 50-second video, so I need to like pop something
into my mouth and eat to show that I'm very nonchalant. I'm actually
so nonchalant and not bothered by making this video." >> I'm
happy I was finally able to wake you out of your slump. Cuz for
a while
you had your pants on and you were just too afraid to have any
conversations with people that disagree with you. >> So,
now we'll watch one of the cultists, this guy, Usurp the Chef,
come in and try to talk to Pisco and try to formulate an argument
this time. >> Everybody on the internet thinks one way
about you and you are the only person who really can't see what
everyone else is seeing right now. >> Isn't it obvious?
>> Go on. >> Cuz you're part of a cult and people
are lying about my views.
LET'S GO!
>> WHAT CULT AM I PART OF? >> You're part of a cult
that considers any
take that is seen on the side of Hasan
indicative of bad faith commie sweeping. And so on that worldview,
of course.
>> Hello, hello, I have no idea what you want to ask me,
so how long is it how long is it going to be? >> Why do
I want to ask you anything? I just thought you were you were
upset about how he described your conversation with Pisco. Do
you have any problem with like my broad characterization that
I agreed with Pisco that you basically sound like a cultist?
You you No, that's didn't seem to understand how you actually
prove things. >> No, that was one of the things that was
annoying with the Pisco conversation cuz every time I've ever
talked to Pisco, you know, we've been chill and it's kind of
like one of the things that, you know, kind of rubs me the wrong
way about him is that, you know, we've had several conversations,
we've never been anything but nice to each other, never even
had disagreement, I don't think. And the one time I come up to
him and I'm like, "Hey, man, I think this might be a little weird.
I might disagree with you on this." That automatically makes
me a cultist, so that's kind of weird. >> You So, you think
he called you a cultist because you disagreed with him? >> Well,
it seemed like cuz that was the only time I had I I had ever
done it. >> Okay, you don't think it had to do with he
was basically asking you how you prove things and you essentially
could not understand how you prove something. So, you immediately
when the first thing when you came on was you said, "You sweep
for leftists
against liberals." That's what it seems like Pisco. You seemed
it seems to me that you sweep for leftists against >> On
when you thought of the show, there was a couple times where
I feel like, you know what, he'll play defense, he'll
>> And so, he was willing to take that criticism and I
asked you to show me show me an instance.
>> Yeah, I had a couple of examples in a sheet and I started
reading them off and he cut me off.
>> Well, so basically, if I'm trying to prove that some
that X phenomenon is
>> and basically you start showing me or I'm I'm showing
you the first example and you go, "Wait, even in the first example,
that's not an example of what you say it is." And then you go,
cuz this is what you did. You go, "Well, I've a I've all of these
I know that this is because I've seen it so many other times."
>> Well, it's like, but you didn't even prove that this
was. So, how am I supposed to trust any of those other examples?
So, at that point you can go to one of the other examples that
you think stands alone or you can admit that you are sort of
begging the question. You're begging the >> yeah, that
I guess that is the one of the difference. Like you and Pisco,
the terminally online guys, cuz you get paid to do this.
You have all the time to like gather >> people who understand
this just read books. It doesn't have to do with the internet.
In fact, I'd say most people on the internet don't understand
this.
Anyway, so basically what I was going in that when he wanted
proof, what I I asked him what kind of proof he wanted. What
did he say? >> So, do you I'm just going to ask, in a meta
sense, do you understand what he was trying to get you to do?
>> He was trying to give me give him examples and not actually
use a feeling that I had to get to the conclusion I
>> After that, he was trying to basically teach you how
you know things about the world, but he was trying to do it without
being an app. >> How do I know things about the world?
Break it down for me.
So, he was basically >> and all that gay >> You have
You have Yeah, you have you have like a you have like a thing
you think is happening, right?
>> Now, how do you show somebody else that it's happening,
especially when they disagree with you? This should be fundamental
to your worldview. You're liberal, right? >> You show them
evidence that will back up your claim that you make. >> Yes.
Yes, exactly. But you you are a liberal, right? So, you believe
in like basically taking the best ideas from multiple schools
of thought, combining them, and yeah, awesome.
so, he was asking you, how would you do this? Because one of
the first things you did was denigrate his use of a dictionary,
right? >> Yeah, because that was going on an argument about
Pisco argument about oh yeah centrist centrist centrist like
I was right you guys were wrong. Yeah. >> And so basically
the analogy I was using for this stream so everybody could understand
what was going on is Pisco is is basically a lawyer. You guys
are in like the 1870s and it's a a town with white and black
people in it. And you're the lawyer on the other side trying
to trying to sentence somebody, okay? And you're going we all
know this did it. We all know he did it, right? And Pisco is
going yeah, but you would need to show us proof. Like we you
don't have you have no evidence. You can't prove he did it. You
can't just accuse him of this thing this horrible thing with
no evidence. And you go come on man Pisco. You're being a little
weird here.
Kind of seeming like a bit of an Edward Scissorhands over here
Pisco. And everybody here gets it Pisco. Everybody here gets
it. We all get it. Why don't you get it >> in order for
me to prove that. Right? I asked him that, right? >> Any
evidence.
>> I asked him what kind of evidence he would like, correct?
>> Why why are you asking him he's asking you to prove
a point. >> Yes. And then here's the thing. What does my
question show him? And what you you answer me that time. >> That
you don't understand how to make arguments that you don't understand
where your beliefs come from. >> that's where you're jumping
to a
Cuz what I had in my mind when I asked him what evidence he wanted
to prove is I was going to do what I did today is actually gather
some evidence because when I had that conversation with Pisco
it was after a 12-hour work day and I had just gotten home 2
hours before that call and I hopped on the call with him. I was
just wanting to talk cuz I had mentioned I had reached out to
him on Discord on Twitter the day of to say like hey man this
whole drama seems weird I want to talk about it and I hopped
on it. So I wasn't expecting to be understandable hey here's
the evidence I didn't have it at the time. >> Did you not
know that he disagreed with
>> Yeah, but I thought we were just going to have a conversation
and talk about things and not be like where's the evidence against
me now prove it now. >> he basically is like incompatible
with his co-host and a terrible friend because he sweeps for
people against them.
>> You just thought you were going to have that conversation
casually. You know that's how it's being used. You are very aware
that this idea that he's like difficult to deal with or impossible
to understand is being weaponized to slander him, yes? >> Yes,
and that is why I went into the conversation looking to have
a conversation between two friends. And Pisco apparently went
into the conversation to defend himself against an attacker.
Okay. That's the
He but he was very kind to you off the bat, right? >> Yeah,
and then he started ramping it up first. He started ramping it
up first. He ramped it up first. >> going to make you I'm
trying to make it clear what you're leaning into I don't know
that you could classify yourself as a friend because what you're
describing to me is you leaning into this idea about Pisco. You're
agreeing with it. You're you even though you're aware it's being
used to slander him. >> Without any evidence of that without
a way to prove that at all with with nothing, right? I don't
know if I would call that a friend. I would expect my friend
to basically give me the benefit of the doubt and to if he wanted
to change his opinion on me to have some evidence or some basis
for
>> Okay. Again, I wasn't going into that interview or into
that conversation with him to say hey you're wrong. I wanted
to get his perspective.
I wasn't going to say hey you're wrong coming into a conversation
with a friend I haven't talked to him about it yet. Why would
I do that?
>> But you talked about it on Twitter.
>> I I made one comment like hey man, yeah, I think this
is wrong. If I see a friend of mine of mine doing something stupid
in real life I might say hey man, this is wrong. And if I might
go and then later if I if I go to work after saying that to my
friend and drive to his house right afterwards I might not have
all the evidence I need in front of me. >> What did he
do that was stupid?
>> Uh wait in our original conversation or from the >> No,
to get you in there that you that you're tweeting about. What
did you do that was stupid? >> Oh, it was the this the
the stupid thing I see Pisco do a lot of times is just
And again, when I even started the conversation, I don't think
he's a secret tankie. I don't think he's necessarily sweeping
for the leftists. What I do think happens sometimes is
part of his personality, which is not whether that is neither
good nor bad, is that he
it seems sometimes, like I said, as an outsider, that he seems
to get to a position
and then stick on that position.
It seems that I have a feeling of that that he does that a lot.
So, I've seen him defend a lot of things. And a lot of times
he's done it as a bit. So, when I see that happening, when I
see him arguing with all of his friends all the time, and sometimes
I'm almost like, "Oh, [__] is this an instance of
him digging his feet into the dirt or not? Or is this something
about him actually sweeping for leftists?" Cuz I don't know.
I mean, I know about all The only thing I know about him is what
he's willing to put out online. Like, I don't hang out with him
every single time. So, every time I see him online, it seems
some contentious shit's happening.
And by contentious, it's like three out of 10 on a scale. >> So,
he's doing something stupid here by digging in um just in general.
Digging in is not stupid like in and of itself, but like I had
said, what I had believed to have been a pattern of similar instances.
Now, I can't even go back and say, "Hey, he was right here or
wrong here, right here or wrong here." But again, you have a
feeling about something cuz you've taken in um information over
time, and I'm a human being, and I forget a lot of [__]
anyway. So, I'm not going to have a good glossary in the back
of my Oh, yeah, on October you did this. But, you you And you
know that to be inherently true. Sometimes you have a feeling
about something, and you're like, "I hate this guy. I don't know
why." So, I just wanted to get clarification on that. That's
all I was going in for. And if you go and listen to the conversation,
he's the one who ramped it up.
>> Well, I think Well, again, I explained to you why you
ramped it up because you and you're aware of of what all this
stuff's going on. So, you came on to represent this thing and
say basically he's wrong and that the reason he's being slided
is his fault. Right? And you think that there's a way you can
do that and be friendly with somebody and just have a normal
heart-to-heart. >> Yeah, cuz sometimes friends have like
tough conversations with each other.
>> Yeah, but I would expect So, what he asked you repeatedly
was well, am I incorrect?
>> Right? And you seemed completely incapable of showing
that he was >> And you >> just said here you don't
know whether or not he's correct, right? So, you came on based
on a feeling. >> talking about. Incorrect on what? I don't
know what you're talking about. Incorrect on what? Just on what?
Incorrect on what? Just say that and continue. Sorry. >> On
either the core concept of centrist and moderate being used interchangeably.
>> Right? Or that's plausible that these two terms can
be used interchangeably. And then the the second thing is that
>> like uh calling Olivia a centrist and whether that was
malicious or not.
>> Yes. Well, no, no, no, no, no. I'm talking about this
core idea that it was plausible whether or not centrist and moderate
are used interchangeably. Like whether it's plausible somebody
would use them interchangeably.
That is the core uh that is a part of the conversation of whether
or not it's >> of the conversation. Like I actually went
through like 80% of the actual Livin' Learn episode. Um because
half the time I'm listening to the anyway, I'm at work. I'm cooking
dinner. One um headphone in my ear anyway. So, um so, I actually
after after I had that conversation and yeah, I even told Pesco
>> I have to reiterate something really >> Go ahead.
>> Every time you sort of distance yourself from knowledge
of the situation that you would join in that situation to argue
this to Pesco makes you look worse. >> Okay, I mean >> while
it may be the case that you did not have have lot of information
there, but it it absolutely makes you look >> you ever
gone into a situation? Can I ask you a question?
>> Like I'm just Hold on. First I have to explain it to
you. I'm accusing >> have to explain it to me, all right?
>> I'm accusing your friend of being a Okay. And you go
to join their stream being unaware of the facts to go, "Listen,
man. People be accusing you being a block."
Do you think you're acting like a
>> Mhm. In that situation? No, I don't think so. But do
you know the difference between those two?
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> One's a crime.
>> understand the trick? >> Do you Okay. What I was
saying originally before you had cut me off >> Sorry, let
me switch it to you and
>> after the conversation with with >> You wait,
you totally dodged the actual meaning of that and you got caught
and you know exactly where the problem is >> Which you're
trying to do you're trying to escape on the fact that it's a
crime alone. But you can clearly understand what I'm pointing
out, right? Do you clearly understand what I'm >> the question
and then I'm going to continue to say what I was going to say
that's going to answer the question. >> like a friend?
>> You think that person is acting like a >> Because
and then here's my question to you that I was asking before you
cut me off. Have you ever gone into a situation thinking that
you knew more about it?
>> And would that make you a bad person? >> I didn't
say you I I said you were a bad friend. I didn't say you were
a bad
That's synonymous in my mind. Like usual Like you know what >> Would
it make you a bad friend? Yes. Yes, because obviously if you're
going to discuss something that's being used to slander your
friend in public, you should apprise yourself of the >> Again,
you say I went in to slander him. >> And not only that
>> I did not go in him. So I don't know why you say that.
>> Piscot, but just Sorry, the situation is being used
you you're arguing a premise that is being used to slander him.
>> And you're aware of that. >> And if we had a that
conversation went a different way, if Piscot didn't like ramp
it up so quickly, it might have gone a different way and it would
have just been us talking. >> You're just doing the exact
same form like gaslighting that was happening
>> Well, you guys you guys you guys are actually off insane.
You know that. >> Because you're saying that if he was
just nicer to you as you were a betting this slander of him that
you maybe could have gotten to the conversation. But it's perfectly
under- I said a betting this slander of him as in you are arguing
a core premise. >> I do not agree with your representation.
I was not saying that I was betting that. It's it's a weak man's
thought. >> A betting, you were helping it happen.
I disagree.
Yes. And you understand it with concept. And it's not just because
it's a crime. You're implying something negative about your friend
without apprising yourself of the situation. >> wanted
to know what was happening. And And I was going into that conversation
>> Actually argued that, "Hey, this is wrong and I think
you have I think you're misinformed. Here's why I think you're
wrong. Look, I'm walking you through. How are you proving this?
Oh, you're proving it poorly. You fought him every single step
of the way." >> Yeah, cuz he called me a cultist. That
pissed me off and I got into fight mode. No [__]
Cuz what that cultist comment was like 5 minutes into the
>> Why did that upset you? >> Well, because when
your friend calls you a cultist, being like what what is what
does that imply? >> It implies that you think you have
knowledge of the situation and you don't because you're getting
your knowledge from a bad source. >> I would more define
like cultist as somebody who's been like completely brainwashed,
doesn't think for >> Yes. Yeah, yeah, that all yeah, it
but I I believe that's >> So, that's pretty insulting,
right? >> Go ahead.
>> Yeah, okay. So, I was insulted and I got
And I could already tell that Pisco was ready to fight, so I
was like, "Why not? Let's fight." >> So, do you have do
you have do you have any concern
about being correct? Do you like not want to win the argument?
>> No, sometimes I would like to be correct. But guess
what? I don't go into every argument
Oh god, I know I'm going to be right. I got to be right cuz I'm
always right. Because guess what? I know I'm wrong sometimes.
I know sometimes I don't have all the information. So, I'm willing
to go into it and be wrong sometimes. >> I'm going to re-walk
you through the >> is exactly why after Pisco, when we
had our conversation, I said, "Hey, listen. I might be mis- I
might be completely wrong in this. And if I am wrong, I'll come
back and apologize." So, what I did today was spend a couple
hours going through all the streams and trying to get all the
information and make sure I have my ducks in a row. Because >> listen,
if I'm wrong, I'll go and apologize. I'll say, "Hey, Pisco, you're
right. I was wrong." >> I'm just re-update here for you
now where we're at in the conversation. You were aware that this
was being used, this idea that he's difficult and that he's like
causing this rift in the show, that it's being used to slander
him. You're aware of that, that he feels that way, that that
that is what's happening, okay? You went on to talk about it
without very much information. When the person was upset, justifiably
so, that you were helping this slander occur,
you got upset yourself and immediately started trying to prove
that it what that the slander was occurring. >> had a feeling
at the time that I was >> So, you were thinking about yourself.
So, again, just in terms of being a good friend, nothing you
did here is the the stuff you would do as a good friend. >> Does
this actually work?
>> Does what work? >> like you like I you know that
you don't have to believe everything >> a logical progression
of facts work? Yes, quite often. Not often when I'm talking to
people in your sphere of the internet, but most of most of the
time for everybody else. Most of the Most of the time for everybody
else. >> You were just mean and you went in to hurt his
feelings.
>> Yeah, he First of all, first of all, first of all >> I
say you went in to hurt his feelings? >> was a big boy.
>> Did I Hold on. Did I say you went in to hurt his feelings?
>> if he didn't want to have the conversation, he didn't
have to. >> I'll let you go. >> So, he's a big boy.
>> Did I Did I say that you went in there to hurt his feelings?
>> You kind of implied it, yeah.
>> I No, I implied that you went in there thinking you
knew what was going on, but you clearly didn't and you got embarrassed
because you knew you couldn't prove it. And so, when he tried
to walk you through how you would prove something, you just kept
implying, "Pisco, why does this keep happening to you? Pisco,
why does everybody in the internet think this about you?" So
in the example it is, "Pisco,
what have you been doing? Why does everybody keep calling you
a I mean you were trying to convince me that you this was a friendly,
helpful >> And in that example why have images where I
accuse him of being a I've seen what I thought to be him doing
Is that work? >> And what did you define as So again, here
it would be something like you were trying to prove that he was
wrong about these things. For sure.
>> Yes. Well, hold on. I'm asking you about the conversation.
So if you've done more research on this then >> to have
a conversation with.
>> Okay, okay. So I'm going to ask you, when you tried
to say that, "Hey, I think this has happened." Is that if So
now you have to admit that if you are using contentions to form
these arguments, basically if you thought something about these
arguments, that is false, that is propagated by someone that
Pisco might think his cult-like, right? Or so by people who are
a part of a cult-like group,
that's what he's seeing and you have to understand that it is
a real phenomenon, that you are wrong because you have watched
the wrong person tell you what's happening here. >> Who
do you think that is? >> Or you have the wrong group of
friends, you have an insular group of friends who all share the
same opinion that seems to be pretty outside of the norm and
not defensible in like a neutral situation. >> So when
I first had the conversation, when I first started, I said, "If
there is an argument between somebody who identifies as a liberal
and someone who identifies as a progressive on your
you seem to take the side and play defense for the progressive
from time to
What does that sound like? Like what level of criticism would
you say >> I said, "If there's an argument between someone
who identifies as a liberal on your show, like the Liberal and
Lean hosts, and someone who identifies as a progressive, you
seem to take the side of of progressive from time to time.
>> That sounds like So, unless
with absent analysis of whether or not that position is correct
and consistent with his own, that sounds like you're suggesting
that he's sympathetic to >> Yeah, from time to time.
Not all time, and then I even went on to say, and then right
after I said that, I said, "Hey, I do not think that you're sympathetic
to lefties. I think you're a liberal. I know you're vote blue
no matter who. That's why I have these questions. That's why
I want to have this conversation. I want to better
>> So, then I said >> didn't want to better understand,
did >> Can you just let me get a couple words out? So,
all I was saying was
here are a couple conversations that I was able to remember on
the drive home that made me feel this way, right? And list I
had tried to list off a couple conversations. Never in the beginning,
never before he called me a cultist, did I come into this conversation.
I almost was going to be able to give him the way say, "Hey,
explain it to me. Tell me Tell me why I'm wrong because this
is the feeling I have, and I might be totally wrong. >> I
wanted you to lead with your fastest >> Hey, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Instead Instead of doing, "Hey, yeah, you know what? I
understand why you have these three these six examples right
here. These two examples I disagree with them because X Y Z.
This example I disagree with X Y Z. The third one, oh, maybe
you're a little bit right on that." And we could have had a conversation
like that, correct? >> I don't know why you would think
you'd get that conversation when you were basically trying to
prove something that if proven validates a bunch of slander that's
happening. >> trying to prove or explicitly disprove something.
Right? Cuz you in your mind, my intention was to go in there
and stomp on him.
Of course that's what your intention is. That's why >> was
to lead into and say, "This is why This is why I think actually
the thing that is core to slandering you is correct. That's not
stopping on him that you you think it's correct. >> went
but you okay, fine. Stopping on him. You don't like that word.
I went in there to kind of discredit him a little bit and to
kind of really make him look bad, right?
>> You said yourself that you were aware that this concept
is being used to slander him. You're doing it in public. You
understand that that is functionally what you were doing, right?
>> No, because when if that's happening, let's say there
is somebody having this conversation and let's say it's your
>> No, I need to No, I need to pause you first. I need
to pause you first.
Were you not under the impression? Was your Was your purpose
in going in there going I I believe this. I am correct on >> No,
it was I have this feeling and I want to know if I'm right or
wrong. >> Okay, you're I you're falling back to just asking
questions, which is quite >> See, okay, I'll tell you what's
like frustrating I guess from like the normie side of this. It's
like
I these conversations I I had a conversation like this with one
of my co-workers
um last week actually. Wait, two weeks ago. And it was one of
the things like, "Hey, I think I'm right about this, but I might
be wrong about this. Help me figure it out." Because listen,
I'm not a genius. I ain't Mensa, all right? I didn't even graduate
college. I'm not a genius. So I I'm I'm one Apparently,
it's it's it's foreign
to people online that somebody can go into a conversation and
not necessarily have this like, "Oh, I'm going to rip your throat
out. This is going like going to be a debate to the death >> You
understand >> going to be 100% right and you're going to
be 100% wrong. That's exactly what you thought this conversation
was going to be. >> I do think I do think you understand
that when you go in
with the the idea that you were going to show that that basically
Pisco is is unreasonable, right? >> right there. You said
it right there. You said it right there. You messed up
>> I go ahead. >> Cuz you had said I was going in
there to
that I am right. >> Sorry, I'm based on your explanation.
I'm going to So I don't think you All right, sorry. I think you
were, but you're going to say, "Well, I was just asking questions.
I just had no idea if I was right or wrong." >> No, I had
this feeling. I believe that I was right, but I wanted to know
if I
And so, I had every conversation I had had with Pesco before
has been cordial. >> you want to talk over me, but I would
like to actually get this point out. Cuz it's it's it's going
to respond to what you just said. So, when you went in there,
again, I'm going to give you the like the raising the stakes
example so that you can understand. So, again, he's being accused
of being a and you're you're basically going in to prove one
of the premises being used to accuse him of being a and you go
in public, "I have no idea whether this is true or false. I just
want to do a sincere walk-through of this cuz I just want to
know the truth." You understand that you are And, by the way,
where you go after that is pretty rough with all of the "Why
does everybody think this about you?" Okay? But, you understand
that that is not something a friend would do, right? You wouldn't
go on and say, "I want to do this in public. We're going to have
this conversation in public."
Right? That you are suggesting by saying you believe it. You
are suggesting it's >> I wasn't sure if it's true. I thought
it might be true. So, if I thought it might be a Is our entire
relationship in public? Is our Has our entire relationship been
in public? >> You said you thought it was correct. It was
the feeling you had. Was it was >> a feeling I had. >> And
was our entire relationship in public true? Was our entire relationship
in public prior?
>> I don't know.
>> If it was, does that make any
>> And that guy is a public person? And he wanted to have
that conversation? >> no difference. >> And he wanted
to have the No, actually, you No, actually, yeah, I would be.
He wanted to have the conversation.
>> He wanted to have the conversation. >> Yes, he
was a In this In this example that you give me, he was a proud
and he wanted to defend it.
>> That's a joke. I know. But, what in the situation that
you gave me, what
in the whole situation >> for this by multiple people.
He's being attacked by >> And you are coming in and going,
"Hey, this is This is like real." >> Why you are ignoring
the defense part?
He's being attacked for If he was just being attacked >> you
understand I don't have any problem with him defending himself.
You're saying that you came in there just asking questions knowing
he was defensive, knowing he was under attack, and you went,
"I just want to see if like the attackers are correct, man."
>> All right.
>> Do you understand? >> I see if that's how you
got this. >> No, I understand how where you're coming from.
I do think that the issue is that
you're coming from it all You obviously already didn't like me
coming into this, so you had a negative view of me, and
basically, no matter what I would say, you would be coming out
with the same stuff because, no matter if you believe me or not,
I wasn't going in there to get her known. Listen, like I'm not
an online guy. All right, I tweet sometimes. So, >> with
this >> trying to do was get a conversation have a conversation
with a friend. And it is what it is. The conversation was the
entire tone.
>> You realized you didn't have evidence. You started gaslighting
him and saying, "Why does everybody think this Pisco? Why does
everybody think this Pisco?" >> As soon as that's happened,
you understand that your the idea that you went in there and
you just didn't want to prove anything really. >> That's
kind of absurd, right? >> Yeah, cuz he made me angry. At
that point, all all all bets are off. I'm [__] pissed
off when you call me a person who's going to >> go and
totally lean into this kind of slander if you're angry at a friend
in
>> You haven't Why are you saying slander like you don't
understand the concept? Like you don't understand what I've been
arguing the whole time. >> Yes, I understand the concept,
but again, I think this is the weak the weakness that is showing
through how this is something that is so like Pisco being bad
faith and sweeping for lefties is like the worst thing in the
world, and oh my god, I can't believe you would go and attack
him for that. It just it was
the drama levels that you guys >> I hate Sorry, I'm laughing
at how badly
how badly you failed to understand the conversation.
That's like the funny thing to me.
And I find it hilarious how you guys clutch your pearls selectively.
>> Oh, yeah.
All right, we can get to that in a little bit. Um
Well, selectively. Okay.
>> I just see Pisco like getting like brigaded on Twitter
and I'm like annoyed because he's correct. Like the the foundational
question that he asked you by the way >> you By the way,
you know he loves that, >> Yes, I've said Well, sorry,
I've said multiple times not when he's being slandered. He doesn't
love it. He's actually quite up and stressed out about >> Okay,
yeah, not being slandered. Again, I don't think I was slandering
him until he made fun of me, but >> But just arguing, yeah,
I do think you could occupy all of Pisco's time in a day by just
buying some chat GPT tokens and training a Twitter bot to go
and argue with him. >> That was the way you could keep
him in a room for like >> Cuz he loves correcting bad arguments.
He would be there forever.
But I still the the slandering part, which is what that whole
thing was about. He He was basically being called a terrible
friend who was like really with his own podcast and all of his
co-hosts and the liberal movement to a larger extent. Maybe he
just can't be on Living Learn anymore because he's just not really
a liberal. No, you didn't say that. I'm telling you what the
thread is
>> Okay. What do I have to do with the [__]
thread?
>> You responded to it and that's how you ended up on the
stream.
I actually DM'd him, too, but yeah.
Anyway, what was your next point? >> My point is
is that uh I don't even >> And the worst the funniest part
is >> so badly. I don't even know my next point. You actually
just mind wiped me by saying
What do I have to do with this What do I have to do with the
thread?
>> Exactly, cuz I wasn't in and I said that because I wasn't
slandering him and saying all the negative things that you were
implying. So, like when you said you were a part of that thread,
you then said, "Hey, you also have to take ownership of some
of the mistakes you've >> You said he loves it.
>> I've lost the thread of where the conversation was.
>> In any way. >> Uh it was that he was basically
being attacked. Oh, yeah, he's being said like, "Oh, you he shouldn't
be on Livin' Learn. Um he should be kicked off the show." This
is all in Hutch's chat. >> would call all all of them saying
all of these things morons.
>> Cuz I think he's good on Livin' Learn. >> want
to be in a community where that was a pervasive thought? >> I
mean,
what do you mean by be in a community where that's pervasive
thought? Like >> Would you want to be in a community where
that was a pervasive thought? >> That he should be kicked
off of Livin'
>> That he was sweeping for Tankies, that he's a bad friend,
that he wants to be kicked off of Livin' that he should be kicked
off of Livin' Learn. Would you be a part of a community where
that is a pervasive thought? >> Um I wouldn't care that
much cuz I don't like really take stock in the way I >> But
you just said [__] all of those people, they're all
morons. So, you want to be a part of a community of morons. >> No,
it's because like I don't know what you mean by community online.
For someone like you who does this for work, that means you interact
with these people for what? 8, 10 hours a day?
I understand how that's a really tight and really important community
for you,
>> Do you Again, do you want I'm just curious, do you want
Do you want to discuss what a community on I'm obviously referring
to Destiny's community, right? >> Yes, I know. And I'm
in like what So, I am in the community >> a mod in his
Twitter community, are you >> Yep. And I have What was
the last time I posted in there? >> in a community where
docs have been posted multiple times. >> posted in that?
>> Have you ever posted in his community? I have no idea.
>> Yeah, cuz apparently, you can make if you're a mod and
you just join a community once when you first see it pop up,
any mod that's in that channel can make anybody else a mod.
Right? So, if I don't have any posts in it and I never work in
it and I never comment in it, it it doesn't like I I know a bunch
of people have made that point in the past. Like I'd be arguing
with somebody on Twitter >> didn't even know it was the
case until somebody chats at it, but I'm like >> Exactly.
Exactly. No, no, no, exactly. So, like this is a a good point
like how I am with view communities online, right? Um you guys
like people have brought that up to me on Twitter in the past
and every time I'm just like, whatever. Like who cares? I'm like
not even going to respond to this because it means nothing to
me. Am I in a random Twitter group that I've been in for probably
a year and a half? >> don't you don't consider yourself
a DGG or you don't watch Destiny's content very often. You don't
you don't >> again, I don't this is the whole part of the
community. I like when you um how oldish are you?
Are you 30s or 20s?
>> Um did you ever lis- listen to Howard Stern or know
that name? >> No, but go ahead. I'm aware. >> he
yeah, big radio shock jock. Like if you were those guys part
of a community?
>> All his fans? >> people who went on the show?
>> No, the people who listened.
>> Yeah, especially if they were part of like especially
if they engaged in conversations like in participating like participating
directly with that community online,
>> Like probably Howard Stern's a difficult example, but
like you do like I recognize you as the person who argues like
on behalf of like liberalism and and but Destiny narrowly, too.
>> Yeah, I'll I'll I'll tell you exactly what my three
Yeah, I'll tell you if you go through my Twitter post, it's going
to be the top three
are going to be
anti-Trump, anti-GOP,
anti-Hasan, and then
probably a mix of retweets of Destiny
um all that. Because the only reason I watch Destiny is for his
political takes because he has a similar political take than
I and I'm a political nut. That's why I don't know any other
streamers, that's why I don't know any of this other stuff and
everything I know is from me listening to him show while I'm
driving, hearing him talk about other things. And right, you
know, you >> So you had no opinion on me?
>> No, I mean I have a little bit of opinion on you. I
was just I actually realized I'm still subbing to you in here.
Hey.
>> I knew that. >> How's it feel? >> Somebody
better sub. Somebody better sub to make up for this guy canceling.
>> Who said I was going to cancel? >> Oh, wait. You
just said you just said you only know about Destiny because of
his political takes and then revealed that you're a 25-month
sub on my >> Yeah, I've been watching him for a >> entirely
entirely disconnected, right? >> Mhm. No, cuz I thought
you were really interesting. Of course, I love the drama, too.
If I'm late at night, I'll watch some of the drama, but I'm listening
to him primarily for his political takes. Like when he did um
What was it last um
The drama with um Abba and um What was her name? The the the
the girl that that they were sleeping with that >> girl
who just
>> What was that? Who did you say? >> who just came
out. That like his baby mama drama like two nights ago. >> Wait.
Wait, no. Wait. Oh, [__] Hold on. >> Talk about
Walter Fresh. >> femoid.
Who Who What was her original
>> Sigma femoid?
>> Lav. Thank you, Jesus Christ.
Like I remember This was what? Two or three years ago during
that whole drama when he >> going to let you know that
that sounded insanely performative to me. Like you pretended
you didn't know who Lav was
>> I have no way to say for sure, but it just sounded insanely
performative to >> Cool. So, I remember when that drama
was happening, I stopped watching because I don't give a [__]
You know what drama I watch? With my wife when we're watching
whatever dumb reality show she has on. I don't like I don't care
for the drama too much. So, basically, I like the political takes.
Now, will I comment on drama here and there? Absolutely. It's
fun sometimes, but that's not what I'm in here for. I'm not on
the computer for 10 hours a day getting into all the
>> I was just pointing out when you said I just watch him
for his political takes, that's obviously not true. >> But
that's why Okay. I watch him >> You fixed it. You fixed
it. You fixed it. You fixed it. You fixed it, okay? >> You
know exactly what I mean. Anyway, so I'm watching him for his
political takes. This all this other [__] is just
mostly white noise to me. Every once in a while I will find some
of this other stuff interesting, but I'm busy, man. Like I don't
Not to say that like I'm better than you, obviously. Like you
This is your job. You're supposed to know all this [__]
You're supposed to know all the minutia. I'm just watching. Sometimes
I'll make a comment and if I'll ask my friend, somebody I thought
was a friend, friendly-ish online, "Hey, I I want to have a conversation
with you." then I'm going to do that anyway. And cuz maybe Maybe
I'm not. Maybe Maybe that was a mistake on my part cuz I don't
know this world that well. Maybe I shouldn't have done it.
just to be clear, um I'm going to I'm going to try to wrap this
back around and give like a concise at the end here point of
why I don't feel like this. You will have to admit you made a
mistake almost certainly here cuz it seems like you're willing
to go and have this conversation with Pisco knowing he was being
attacked on the basis of not being a good friend, being a uh
poor, you know, co-host or live and learn on the basis of maybe
having tanky sympathies. Okay, you knew this and you went into
a >> literally if there's an argument between someone who
identifies as a liberal or >> are the things people were
arguing and you were aware of them. And you went on to say, "Hey,
there's a I have a feeling that these are true, right?" And then
you got angry at him when he felt justifiably like a little annoyed
at about it or was aggressive in your question.
>> When you say um when I come into the conversation and
I say, "Hey, you know, there's been speak some drama online.
I have some questions and I want to figure out if these are true."
That is different than, "Hey, all these people have been saying
all these things and I want to know if all these things are true,
right?" There's a difference between those two
>> Because if I wanted to go If I went into the conversation
saying, "Hey, all like let's go through this Twitter thread.
I'm going to defend all these attacks against you." I would agree
with you. But I had actually spent a little bit of time to try
and gather some information of the questions that I had. Again,
going into the conversation thinking that I might be wrong. And
I like Pisco, that's why I wanted him to prove me
So, I went into that conversation >> proving you wrong
and said that the basis of your information is probably this
community you're in that says these things about me with no basis.
>> Exactly, because he was >> got angry and started
just leaning into the idea that everybody thinks it. So, when
you say everybody thinks it, what did you mean by everybody?
>> When did I say that?
>> You said everybody thinks this. Why does everybody think
this about you, Pisco? Why does everybody think >> after
you called me a cultist?
>> Yes, but I'm I understand you were upset. I'm saying
he pointed out cultist is pointing out that you're getting information
from a biased place. And you started going everybody thinks this
about you, Pisco. Everybody thinks everybody sees it my way,
Pisco.
>> Cuz I was being mean at that point. Yeah. Again, at
that point he was a he was being a So, I'm going to be a back.
>> And you felt that those are equal amounts of being a
that when he said you're in a cult, that was an is an equal amount
of leaning into the attacks that are being used to say you should
be kicked off of his podcast none of his network to go for like
co-host friends. >> leaning into those attacks. Nope. But,
you know what? It was >> you say Pisco, everybody thinks
this about you. Everybody thinks that you like that you defend
leftists over liberals. That is what you came in to say. That's
your perception. And if what is everybody think this? What is
everybody >> keep saying that? Why do you keep Why do you
keep switching at the very end? It's not what I went in there
to say. Right? We've been over this and you agreed with me. >> Okay.
So, you you said you thought I was saying that, right? >> ready
to have >> Wait, hold on. Hold on. I actually need to see
the cult part now. Hold on. I actually need to see this. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. >> cuz we got like 10 more minutes, man.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh well, you go ahead and respond
however you want and I need the the cult >> So, all I was
saying is I was going in there to have a normal conversation.
He turned the temperature up. I'm going to respond in kind. And
then when he insults me and calls me a cult member, someone who
doesn't think for himself, then I'm not going to hold back on
anything. And I might say things that upset him.
>> But you understand you hadn't thought for yourself.
You hadn't even >> No, I did think for myself because I
I show these things, right? No, because you're forgetting the
other things. Do you forgetting the fact that I went in and actually
gathered some thoughts of my own. Things that I didn't get from
anywhere else. Think I didn't sit down and listen to a stream
and write questions. I went through all of his old shows. I went
through his Lib and Learn library and went say, "Oh, I remember
this episode. I remember thinking that about this episode. Hey,
I remember this episode. I remember feeling that like the in
this episode." Because I was going through my previous experiences.
Because I sub to Lib and Learn and I watch all their episodes.
>> Okay. Do you think that if basically so the core premise,
this is just one more question then I'll try to find this timestamp.
The core premise of what Pesco is saying in return is essentially
if if when he is arguing those things, when he's taking the sides
of the leftists so to speak, when you when you think he's doing
that, if
basically he's either correct or you're misunderstanding what's
happening in all of those cases.
If you if those if every one of those misunderstandings align
with who he's referring to as the cult-like group,
what do you think that has any meaning? The cult-like group you're
a part of by the way. >> I would say it could. However,
I think this is different because but cuz those are the only
times they really argue on the show. There would be no other
examples of it. So, I wouldn't have that like that criticism
wouldn't exist,
>> I'm sure they argue about other things, too. I know
Hutch and Destin have argued about other things, but >> Like
when I say that, it's like the cuz what triggered it was cuz
like they'll have like, you know, little tips like Hutch and
him will go at it or even him and Soy Pillow or him and IRI.
They'll go out on about like normal regular things and
I don't care about that. Like what what kind of had me going
with this one was the fact that when I went online and I saw
that that he had like the the tweet thread celebrating like he
was right.
>> What is the claim you're trying >> I've been trying
to wonder Let's see. >> But I wonder what happened before
that, >> Am I trying to prove >> What is the claim
you're trying to >> I'm trying to wonder why everybody
on the internet thinks one way about you, and you are the only
person who really can't see what everyone else is seeing right
now. >> Isn't it obvious? >> Go on. >> Cuz
you're a part of a cult, and people are lying about my views.
>> What cult am I a
>> No, he does it in response to you saying everybody thinks
this about you. It is like his response to >> to need to
go back >> doing something where you say everybody thinks
this about you. We can go back. It's going to be you guys arguing
about how you are trying to prove something,
>> So, hold on. I'll go back. Let me grab this tablet.
>> wait. Here. Before you go back, can I explain my memory
of it? >> No, we can watch it. No, we can I literally No,
cuz I don't have No, no, >> I'm fine with you saying you
misremembered, but that is what you need to remind me of. >> want
to Do you want to do it? I got like 10 more minutes left. Five
more minutes left. >> Well, it's only I only go back like
60 >> Okay, go. No, cuz I need to go back like 5 minutes
where he's like freaking the [__] out at me, my memory
serves me
>> I mean, but you said he said you were in a cult. That's
what upset you. >> What he said >> What he said upset
it you for before this, or what he's like frustrated with you
for before this. >> I was upset about I was upset about
that. Because I literally thought that I got angry right afterwards,
but I had gotten angry
20 seconds after instead of 20 seconds before. So, I'm so sorry.
Like it would be I think this would hit a lot better if that
cult comment was like several minutes apart instead of 20 seconds
apart. >> So, what happened in this conversation?
He spent 10 minutes trying to explain to you that you were failing
to prove something and your your core criticism of him was that
he was being like difficult, but he was trying to explain to
you that like epistemically you have a major flaw. You don't
understand how to prove information.
>> You just kept pushing against him and pushing against
him and not proving things and you're saying things that showed
that you couldn't prove the idea that you had. And so, when you
said, "Why does everybody believe you believe this about you,
Pisco? Why is everybody on the same page? I'm just wondering
why everyone thinks this about you, Pisco. Why everyone's on
the same page?"
>> He says, "Well, that's because you believe people who
are lying about me."
Now, you're you're basically telling me that you feel like you're
a friend of Pisco's while being a part of the group of people
that are making things up about this guy, that are lying about
>> You understand why I don't take you seriously when you
say you're a friend of Pisco's? >> You don't take me seriously
as a friend of Pisco's because I had questions about him. Okay.
Makes sense. >> That's what I said. Okay. Anyway, sorry.
Now, you can go ahead. I understand I've been talking for a while.
>> That is what I had said. That's the one thing that you're
completely ignoring this entire conversation, but whatever. >> We
should We should probably go if you got to go in like 5 or 10
minutes cuz I think you wanted to ask me a question, >> Yeah,
what was that question? Remember what it was? Oh, what were you
Oh, actually, no. You answered the question at the very beginning
accidentally.
>> You explained that tweet cuz I didn't get it. It made
no sense to me.
>> All right.
>> All right. Uh then, did you want to respond to any of
this? >> Any of what? The video? Yeah. So, in that video,
in the first 10 minutes of that conversation, and guess what?
You guys aren't going to believe me. I don't give a [__]
I went in to going to have an honest conversation and Pisco,
like I've said since the beginning of this conversation, came
in heated. Now,
maybe I'm mistaken. Maybe I should have realized that he was
going to come in heated because I was going into that conversation,
again, thinking I was going to have the same conversations I've
had with him in the past. It didn't happen because he was heated.
>> honest with you. I remember another one of your conversations
you'd had with him in the past being very similar feeling to
me. Like where you are you're basically pushing you're basically
I yeah, I feel like you're trying to make him look like a bad
person. >> Mhm. All those all those other live combos I've
never had with him?
>> You had a No, you had another live combo. I believe
it was about him being a good friend or not, right? Am I crazy?
>> Oh, this >> Adam Aikler combo? Oh, was that what
it I thought there was a time where you basically were like,
you should talk to Destiny about this. Which one was that?
>> thinking about? >> Oh, what was that? Wait, what
was that >> Now, I want to say in my head it's the Hutch
conversation about you were basically arguing this is why like
you I feel like it People are saying Adam Aikler. Maybe it Maybe
it is Adam >> Well, but what was the Adam Aikler
>> I can't remember.
>> Adam Aikler? Maybe must It must not have been him. Um
let me see. >> Adam didn't go hard enough on Hasan. Oh,
I do remember that one as well. Yeah, I do remember that one
as well. >> Which one was that? >> You wanted to
argue with Pisco that Adam Aikler Oh, I think Pisco Oh, right.
Pisco was Pisco was doing a bit in this one. That was I think
a bit. >> Yeah, that was like Yeah, that whole thing was
a bit, right? >> not the conversation that I'm talking
>> Yeah, that was that was the one at the end when he talked
to Destiny. That was that one. And I honestly went in Yeah, and
I fed him like I I fed the troll the entire I asked him a couple
times, "Hey, are you doing a bit?" And I just I went along with
it the entire time. Well, for the first like 20 30 minutes that
he did the bit, and then we had a conversation.
And guess what? After that conversation, at least from my perspective,
we were still cool. So. >> Yeah, I I'm saying I got the
feeling. I don't think he got the feeling. But I also could be
confusing you with somebody else cuz I have a very strong >> so
like let me just round it out. I'll log off after this. Listen,
I did I'll admit it. [__] I went into that conversation,
and 10 minutes into it when I realized what Pisco was going through
and how angry he was and how heated he was and how and how angry
he was and how heated he was and how potentially angry he was
at me.
I was you know, I was like, oh [__] I got to defend
myself here real quick. And I actually didn't have to do that.
I didn't He In my In my mind, I think if we if I cuz I listened
back a little bit again this morning, um in the beginning when
he was like questioning me about my list of of conversations
that I had remembered him having these rough conversations with,
that was when he was like asking me for evidence. And I think
that was before this comment or this timestamp in this video.
And in my mind, he was being very >> indicative of him
being angry? >> It was also like the you know how it's
with someone's tone and the way they're talking, you can kind
of tell how they're feeling?
maybe, but you you have to understand that that is essentially,
in my opinion, because somehow you you want to
>> No, I >> This is how it looks to him, okay? Is
you are essentially implying something about him with no evidence,
and you are running from him trying to pin down exactly how you
would obtain that evidence or even make that argument in the
first place, which means you are implying something, and you
are whether you want to or not. >> we had we had we had
we had this conversation. We had we had this this this back and
forth earlier. I understand why he may have thought that because
he was probably cuz I don't know all the he was dealing with
on Twitter all day, right? I have no idea what he was going through.
So, when he came in and he was hot, and I brought up my examples,
and he wanted to go deep into them so I can pull out oh, when
I said
in uh Hutch argument voting for Hasan Advance. It's a very I
like I said earlier, I had a very high general I went through
his list and I said, "Hey, I remember feeling this way about
these
So, I was going in to say, "Hey, this is why I feel like this.
Why am I wrong?" And then instead of Pisco being like, "Hey,
man, okay, this is why you feel like this. I think you're wrong
because hey, let me show you." He said, "Hey, shut up. Are you
thinking I'm wrong? Give me the proof. Where is it?" And I'm
like, "Well, I don't have it. I don't have any evidence. Like,
what evidence would you want me to see?" So, I'm already on the
defensive cuz I'm just not expecting this type of conversation.
And maybe that was me being me. May- maybe that was me being
naive. Very well possible. But, if you want to think that I went
in there just to own him because I'm a cultist, >> You
told me you were aware of the things people were saying and that
that's what he was dealing with. You told me that in this conversation.
>> And I didn't And I wasn't aware that he so angry that
we wouldn't be able to have a normal conversation like we've
had in the past.
>> Um also, the evidence bit where you're asking what evidence
would you need me to show you, that's after the comments we're
looking at. >> Oh, is it? Then, something else Then, there
was something else before that that upset me. Or that had like
gotten me kind of like, riled up. But, again, all I wanted to
do was have the conversation. And he came in Now, again, I'm
not mad at him. He was going through more than I was. >> he
came in heated with Hutch during Libel Lauren?
>> Which one?
>> The Taylor Lorenz one. >> The the the um actual
conversation with Taylor or the post conversation? >> The
actual conversation with Taylor. >> Um was he heated like
from the jump What So, sorry. Was Pisco um heated from the jump
in that conversation? Is that the >> Towards Hutch, yes.
>> Towards Hutch, no.
Not the beginning, no. Cuz I think it was like the first like
30 minutes of the conversation. Like, it really didn't start
to get contentious until about 48 minutes in. >> Oh, no.
I'm talking about cuz that's when they start talking about what
I'm I'm talking about the Taylor Lorenz part of the Sorry, the
chorus part of the conversation. So, the second it goes >> Okay,
no. >> the second it goes there, are you under the impression
that Pisco was being hard on Hutch? >> No. That didn't
happen until
bop bop bop bop ba.
I would say about
That's 48 minutes. Probably about not until like 25 minutes into
the
So that the at the very beginning, no. >> The Taylor Lorenz
part of the >> Yeah, 25 minutes into the after the start
of that course part. Sorry. >> you're going to take issue
>> Okay. Now
>> your impression of how Hutch was responding to Pisco's
comments before >> Pisco so >> Pisco tried to basically
say like, "Hey, maybe we could ask this." Do you remember Hutch
responding to >> Oh, yeah. He was like cutting He was saying
like Pisco, wait. Like kind of saying like, "Hey, wait."
>> Do you think he was doing that in a neutral way? >> No,
he was I He was probably, you know,
>> with like random sort of characterizations. And again,
I >> it's random. I think it was deliberate. I think it
was deliberate >> I guess you can say >> get to there?
I mean like I mean Why don't Why don't you go there? Just ask
>> copy editor. >> I'm trying to have a conversation
with her. I don't know why you're jumping in >> Hey, no,
no, no, no, no, no, because it's kind of
What do you think of that way of >> That's a little spicy,
yeah. Oh, sorry. Oh, double. Yeah, that's a little >> Condescending,
right? >> Yeah, a little snap. Yeah, a little sassy. They've
been having arguments like that back and forth for months. >> when
Hutch I just want to say when Hutch goes into basically talk
to Pisco, he seems totally unaware of how condescending he was
to Pisco before Pisco ever got to a yes or no. >> So given
that that's the thing and everybody's freaking out about Pisco
getting to a yes or no point or even becoming like a little heated
himself, do you think it's like an important piece of information
to understand that Hutch was getting like openly condescending
towards Pisco? >> I think if you just take this in a vacuum,
yes.
>> Do you think it's like Okay. I would have to I will
I would would want to run you through some other stuff, but I
know you got to go. >> Yeah, and the only reason I say
in a vacuum is like yeah, if this was the only time they've ever
talked, I'd be like, "God damn, why is he being such a dickhead?"
But you have to be You have to be real here. These guys have
a history of >> Actually, a lot worse that he's being a
[__] given that he's run to another community that
he knows goes after Pisco specifically to complain about Pisco
being a [__] Or sorry, that he's like had conversations
and come in and and made Pisco look that way. I think it's very
intentional, but it's a longer argument, so a very um complex
argument to build up, but >> Yeah, very >> I just
want you to be thinking about that when they interact that like
basically Hutch is sort of like you. He doesn't care if there's
a community that's like essentially lying about one of his friends.
That doesn't really affect his thought process at all. He doesn't
really care. >> Yeah, that's different though. He's like
the leader of the community, right? >> No, he's odd. >> Oh,
you're talking that he's a member of Destiny's community, not
Hutch's >> He's just he's totally fine. He's not like uh
concerned about that. He doesn't think about that. That doesn't
interest thought process.
Got you. Yeah, I'll think about it. >> And here's the thing
and here's the thing. I do I am actually going to have another
conversation with Pisco or I hope to because I did
I literally went through the entire Taylor Rains course part
of the conversation because
believe me or not, I don't give a [__] about being
right or wrong. I just wanted to have a conversation and figure
out what was happening. So, I went I broke down like sentence
by sentence this conversation and while I don't think Pisco like
the um arguments I had for Pisco in the very beginning are the
ones I would still stand to now.
I do think Pisco made some mistakes in the conversation, but
I don't think they were sweeping for lefties. I'll say that.
I don't think the mistakes he made were necessarily sweeping
for lefties. I think it more has to do with
>> So, you You went and watched this whole conversation.
Did you have anything written down about Hutch's
>> No. Wait, when was that? Um
>> 55 minutes into the overall video, the VOD on the website.
>> Give me the exact time. Can you give me the exact time
stamp? >> 55 minutes, 55:30 into the Live and Learn VOD.
>> 55:30? Here, play it real um Play the 10 seconds before.
>> I just played it to you. You said it was spicy. Right?
>> I know, but just remind me so I can play >> sort
of characterizations. And again, I >> it's random. I don't
think it was deliberate. I think it was deliberate >> I
guess >> Well, why don't you get to there? I mean like
I mean why don't why don't you go there and just ask Taylor?
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with her. I don't
know why you're jumping in >> No, no, because it's kind
of a stupid critique to be like, "Hey, uh you know, centrist
is kind of in the eye of the beholder." Like yeah, so Joe Biden
would describe himself as a centrist Democrat, correct? Yes or
no? >> No, Pisco >> Yeah, right here. Hutch agree
or argues back that it wasn't a random characterization, but
a um deliberate one with the goal of signaling to her audience
that she's being Olivia is not on the team. Pisco jumps in asking
Hutch why he doesn't just go there (in parentheses) and by there,
I believe he means Hutch's claim that Taylor used the term centrist
as a pejorative.
Hutch snaps back trying saying that he's trying to have a conversation
or having Jesus. Trying to have a convo >> have a conversation
here. >> and asks why Pisco is jumping in. So, >> I'll
be real. So, that's better than I >> Yeah. And listen,
here, I am going to show you a wee bit of good faith, mate. I'll
send it. >> Right. Actually, I'll send it to you after
this cuz I got to go. But, I'm talking to you. I would like to
continue this at one point. And
yeah, whatever. Thanks for having me on.
Yeah, thanks for coming on. Talk to you later. Bye.
>> I can be perfectly like um polite there, but I think
I made my points well. I I think that that it just doesn't it
doesn't add up to me. I just don't think there's any reason to
berate there or become like hostile in the conversation. We're
going to do a Benny call-in really quickly. Let me go find Benny.
What's up, Benny? How's it going? Oh, I think Sunday just came
in, okay? Let's roll back to when Sunday joins.
Or a little bit closer. Sunday's essentially trying to get to
the argument of you guys are being paid by Progressive Victory,
but not for content at all. And it's like, "Okay, what do you
do outside of the content?" And basically, the argument is I'm
getting paid a thousand to fifteen hundred. Okay, sure. Yeah,
we could do that Benny. Hold on. Benny wants to call it. I think
we added another hour earlier. Yeah, we did. Guys, if you like
the content, go ahead throw a couple subs my way. Subs on kick
help a lot. Any donos, any anything we could add more time to
the stream. Okay, every donation adds more time to the stream.
Well, technically if we reach certain milestones. I believe we
are
Sorry, five subs away from another hour on the stream right now.
Thank you guys so much for being here. What a stream. We're going
to do a Benny call in really quickly. Let me go find Benny. What's
up Benny? How's it going?
Was that this usurp? Yes, it was. What's up Benny? How's it going?
>> Yeah, I uh I I was I was listening to that conversation
and uh I think um
I think I think that you don't
I'm not sure how capable of this you are, but I don't think that
you emphasize enough how or at least in this conversation I don't
think you emphasize enough how evil like this guy was being.
And I'm not saying that he is an evil person, but like the things
that he was doing were so like they were so cruel and and and
and and horrible. Um and I feel like he I feel like he he had
a conversation he's like, "Oh yeah, it was a good conversation.
There was some mutual understanding had." But I don't think he
really understands like how wrong he was
in the things that he was doing.
>> So, there's a limit to how much you could do that in
a conversation and this is a I think the big difference between
like a content creator like me or Queenman is Queenman wants
to do what you want to do, right? And I think that's good, but
I think you don't even get to being able to do that or analyze
the conversation without having a more neutral tone and being
able to walk through it. And so while I agree, I do think there
are some bad things there. I really do. Um I think it's listen,
I'm the forever optimist cuz I've had that conversation and been
optimistic about it before and I have been so [__]
wrong and people have gone on to like share information with
Destiny gets people docs all kinds of [__] right
even after I've done those calm conversations but I'm the forever
optimist I fell for it again maybe maybe being a little softer
about it will help him like think through some of those things
cuz when you attack people they tend to harden their positions
and double down. So anyway with all that said you can go ahead
and give me your analysis of it.
>> It's just like I mean realistically you you covered
a lot of it but I just feel
I feel like he does not understand and and he should because
he's a grown man
right it's not like you're talking to a child. Like he goes into
a conversation
with somebody that he claims to be his friend it's really evil
he goes into the conversation with somebody who he claims to
be his friend who he knows
another community has been attacking him trying to discredit
him and this is what he does for a living
he believes in what he's doing so strongly he quit his job as
a lawyer
in order to try to help politically the Democrats in this country
he believes in and another community has been attacking him and
his credibility saying that he's bad faith he's a liar they've
been essentially trying to hit him against his friend and his
co-host maybe he doesn't believe that part but he certainly believes
those other parts about this other community attacking him and
he goes in right with this idea oh you know I'm just I'm just
asking questions I'm just trying to figure out what you think
and when he realizes and he should have realized that he had
no evidence to back up anything that he was saying instead of
having some humility
and take >> Hey good sign and that is certainly indicative
of you've got a deeply held belief that is being offended when
you
and it was before by the way it was
he was called the cultist.
So that was the original thing.
>> It and it's just like >> Go ahead. >> It's
just like he has no humility to take stock of himself and and
recognize, well, you know, maybe I had the wrong impression here.
And then when Pisco offers his interpretation of why these things
are happening, right? Because he started out by saying, "Why
does everybody think about you?" Again, no humility to even understand
that he's saying that everybody on the internet thinks this about
him when it's really just one community that he's a part of.
When Pisco offers his interpretation he gets personally offended
as this person is substantiating, trying to substantiate the
claims that Pisco is a lying, malicious piece of [__]
who's doing this for a living. >> fair, he's To be fair,
he's substantiating a claim that is fundamental to that that
higher claim, but right? Like it's So, but I think he understood
that or he told me he understood that, right? It's like, "If
I can show that you sweep for lefties, you're basically like
[__] over your friends and a bunch of other people
by doing this, right? You are a lying piece of shit." Like he
understood the chain of causality there and what he was arguing.
So, I will say in in effect he was arguing that or arguing Yeah,
in effect he's arguing that, but I do I will say he was arguing
only one portion of it. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, yeah. I I I agree with that. Um
and I you know, I just want to say, you know, not to not to gas
myself up, but I had an experience like this as well. After
Mr. Girl was taken out back and shot. Um I remember one time
I went on his hotline and at that time I was still under the
effects of some of the brainwashing and I was like, "Oh, you
know, I don't I think that some of your claims are a little dubious.
I don't think it's fair to call Destiny an abuser and the la
la la."
>> And And again, it's a similar scenario where this massive
community is attacking him constantly.
Um and they're trying to discredit him. Again, he does this for
a living, too. And here I come, somebody who claims to be his
friend or at least friendly with him, and I'm essentially discrediting
all the things that he's going through, all the things that he's
being affected by, and Mr. Girl, similar to Pisco, said, "Well,
I think it's because you're so brainwashed." So, he said I'm
in a cult. And I didn't take offense to that and start you know,
memeing or trolling or trying to get Mr. Girl angry. I took it
in stride because he has the right to think how he thinks, and
I have the right to think how I think, even though I was wrong.
I can understand that. And this guy thinks that he's justified
in his behavior like like
And so, I mean all of you already understand this, but it's just
like You go ahead, go ahead. >> the funny thing is is yeah,
it was like
if it wasn't in response to the everybody why does everybody
think this about you, if it wasn't in response to I would understand
like I was kind of like, okay, you got angry and you're like
a selfish person doing this to your friend. But like once once
I had that flipped on me, it wasn't even like it was once he
started essentially going, well, everybody around me thinks this,
it's like, oh, it's actually a pretty solid response. Like it's
actually you're basically saying I can't prove this, you've shown
you can't prove it, and then you go, but why does everybody think
it? It's like, well, hey, I don't know how to tell you this,
man. >> It's it's you sound like you're part of a cult.
>> Yeah, it's as yeah, it's straight funny. >> Yeah,
but he actually joined the live chat. Can somebody send me a
screenshot of whatever he said when he joined the live chat?
>> Yeah, I was just saying like I just wanted to really
emphasize and I hope I hope he listens back to it because I'm
doing this out of you know, a desire to make him feel bad or
[__] on him. I'm saying it because like it it was
it was really like disconcerting. Like I was watching and I was
like, this is like really wrong what you're doing, especially
when as far as I'm concerned, you're you're like concern trolling
and pretending to be Pisco's friend while you're doing these
really heinous things to him. Like I hope he watches that back
and he goes, yeah, my behavior was kind of out of line, all things
considered. E- even if I do still believe these things that this
community is saying about him, my behavior
my response is out of line. >> Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's
another reason I didn't want to go too hard on him is I I do
think that there's a decent chance that he might be able to look
at. Like even if he doesn't think he's in a cult,
Which is I understand that's going to be bad if he doesn't realize,
but even if he doesn't think that, he could at least go on Pisco's
stream be like, "Hey, I like got needlessly upset and I understand
better what was going on and I understand that I was kind of
like I was arguing basically that you're a bad person in essence
and I apologize for doing that cuz I do consider us friends or
something. Although I don't understand how you could I I felt
like the "Well, would you stay a part of that group?" That that
question to me I was just like, "I know the answer to it, but
I have to ask, would you stay a part of a group who was lying
about Pisco like this? Who was saying these things?" Cuz he just
said he said, "Oh, anybody who says Pisco is like against liberals
or hurting Democrats or any of this stuff, those are losers.
I totally disavow them." I'm like, "Well, would you be a part
of a group who broadly believes that?" He's like, "I don't I
don't even know what that means. What is a group? What is a >> Yeah,
that's pretty like I I didn't >> Who knew he could transform
into a lefty that quickly who suddenly made discourse impossible
through not understanding simple terms?
>> What the I have one more thing.
Yeah, okay. Then the last thing is I I feel like this is more
like a kind of a broader trend where um Destiny and his entire
cult, they get to act any way they want and treat people in any
way they want and everybody else who like you know, it goes against
them for lack of a better term, has to just deal with whatever
horse [__] that they throw um their way. Like considering
everything that Mr. Girl went through, the the patience with
which he spoke to people who are still a part of the cult, who
still argue that he was wrong, is unbelievable. The patience
with which uh Pisco argues with these people is unbelievable.
If it was me, I wouldn't even be able to be friends with Hutch
anymore if cuz cuz I remember the conversation that he had with
Hutch when I think it started out with Pisco speaking with Destiny
and Destiny was arguing that Pisco is being a bad friend. The
idea that Destiny could even have the audacity to say that anybody's
being a bad friend in comparison to is unbelievable. But he was
saying that about Pisco and then Hutch joined in with this with
this bastard with this Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know. I I could not
even be friend and Pisco at the end of the conversation
made the concession. Nobody can say anything
about negative about this guy anymore. That's how much he cares
about him and Hutch doesn't give a [__] I wouldn't
even be able to talk to him anymore. I feel like these things
are It's not It's really the the emotional like morality of it
is I feel like it's not really highlighted enough how evil
a lot of this behavior is. One-sided is >> Cuz you're not
you're not upset or annoyed about it enough yet. But then watching
the conversation between Pisco and Hutch that everybody's upset
about, watching that conversation and watching it with Hutch's
chat all saying Pisco's a bad faith lying like loser who is fat
and needs to be kicked off of Livin' Learn. That's like wow.
So we just didn't do any reciprocity here then. And by the way,
I don't think necessarily people should have to moderate that
their chat that hard, right? Like I I I think basically you could
just not look at it. There There are some like longer-term outcomes
there that could be indicate like bad. So I think the good thing
to do is to basically like keep it under control still going
after your friend. Like if they say something you disagree with,
you could point that out. I I think there's probably
but I it's like a very it's much more complex. Anyway, just no
reciprocity. You know what I mean? No reciprocity for >> Yeah,
it's it's really it's really gross. And and again, this is this
is I mean this is just the you know, cherry on top. That filthy
Let me chill. Destiny coming in and being like, you know, your
your chat is saying things about people that's just not even
true. Like they're calling me a pedophile and it's like Look,
man.
I don't know if I would say that you're a pedophile. But why
are you why is he pretending like this is a ridiculous thing
for somebody to It's not ridiculous for somebody to say that.
It's like
like and and and with Hutch, too, it's like people are saying
that I'm pro-genocide. Look, that's probably more ridiculous
than the Destiny thing. But it's like this is this is a part
of the thing. You go online, you put your opinion out there,
people are going to say things about you and say things about
things that you believe that you don't like that that are going
to make you upset that you feel like misrepresents it. But for
you to saddle all that on Peasego as if he's some sort of evil
person. Meanwhile, people can say whatever he wants they want
about him in their chats and in in his own chat. Like it's it's
unbelievable, man. It's unbelievable. It's so wrong. It's so
wrong.
Yeah, it's like and unfortunately, cuz I do know sometimes I
think my I can sometimes like start to get away from covering
that stuff. I'm glad that you're saying this cuz you know that
I do feel this way. Cuz sometimes I get away from covering Destiny
Jason stuff and
but then I watch like
I watch what's happening
and I do feel I
I wouldn't say I felt this a lot with like the the Pixie stuff
as much that I it wasn't like some moral crusade even though
people frame it that way. It was like no, he's like a bad person,
but it wasn't like
There was some stuff in there anyway. I I shouldn't even Regardless,
with this stuff, I actually do feel that it's like just wrong
that nobody else will say anything. That like all the friends
around Peasego aren't saying anything. I actually like I get
if I think about it for too long, I get very angry and I have
to like calm myself down. Cuz I'm like watching basically what
happened to me over time happen to Peasego in real time. And
I'm like, bro, how many times do you got to like has anybody
shown these people the "And Then They Came for Me" little poem
that exists. I didn't they They for these people, I didn't stand
up, they came for these people, I didn't say anything, then there's
no one left to speak for me. Have any of you seen it? Have any
of you seen this? Jesus Christ.
>> Well, that's that's all I really wanted to say. I didn't
realize that that guy was, you know, wasn't going to be on for
so long. Kind of I I wanted to say it to him, but, you know,
obviously, you know, if there's not a lot of time, I don't want
to take up any, but
>> I would be legitimately shocked if he didn't go and
um if he didn't go and look at it. Or if he's not going to go
and look at this, I feel like he would look at the commentary
after. Or somebody will tell him to go look at the commentary
after, right? You'd assume.
>> Yeah. So, I I feel like he'll see it.
>> Mhm. Okay. >> Yeah, it's just it's Yeah, it's
frustrating to watch, man. Thanks for coming on. >> All
right, peace out.
>> Have a good one. Bye.